ans
ce sera devant pau pas
je peux faire un test
c'est bon
novelli
cela
je crois
sa chanson formidable
on adore aura pas de dépendance
comment
je récupère
serrières à droite
[Musique]
c'est bon
alors directement
hélas
bien mesdames et messieurs
c'est d'abord remercier monsieur le
maire de villeneuve-la-garenne de nous
et que nous accueillir dans sa commune
et le bâtiment qui est derrière moi
montre d'ailleurs l'importance de cette
ce secteur pharmaceutique
ici même dans cette commune puisque
depuis la fin du 19e siècle ici on
produit de la pharmacie ce qu'il faut
pour rogner nos concitoyens et ce qui
montre l'importance de cette industrie
sur ce territoire est ici même alors
dans cette période où nous avons
aujourd'hui à continuer à nous battre
contre le virus pour en ralentir la
diffusion à apprendre aussi à vivre avec
le co vite 19 et dans un contexte où
leurs décisions ont été prises pour
préparer la rentrée scolaire et
poursuivre l'activité économique dans
tous les secteurs accompagné des
secteurs en difficulté avec le ministre
de l'économie des finances le président
de la commission des affaires
économiques de l'assemblée nationale
nous voulions être ici présents pour
aussi montré qu'il faut regarder devant
et que dans ce contexte sanitaire
justement sur ces sujets sanitaires de
santé de pharmacie
la france a non seulement des atouts
mais un avenir et un avenir pour
relocaliser et nous sommes ici sur un
site industriel pharmaceutique
d'exception dans une entreprise qui a
montré toute sa force il faut vraiment
féliciter au président directeur général
c'est quoi c'est en effet un fleuron
français une formidable entreprise de
taille intermédiaire qui en 15 ans est
passé 2 s'est démultiplié sur le sol
français et dans le monde sur le sujet
justement des principes actifs a montré
sa capacité à se mobiliser et à produire
est passé de trois à quatorze titres que
vous m'expliquez durant la visite est
donc cette entreprise de taille
intermédiaire elle est exemplaire parce
qu'elle a su innover sur le sujet des
principes actifs parce qu'elle a su
embauché aussi et innover en matière
sociale et nous en avons vu toute la
force avec les quelques profils qui nous
ont été présentés ici c'est à dire c'est
une entreprise qui croît dans la
jeunesse de notre pays qui à développer
l'alternance l'apprentissage qui croient
dans sa recherche et son développement
et qui par une logique partenariale on
l'a vu sur le projet qui est ici
développé avec un partenaire mirta va
justement sur la base d'un os trogen
développer un principe actif pour
permettre la recherche permettent
d'avancer et bâtir avec son partenaire
de nouveaux médicaments et donc je veux
vraiment insister sur le caractère
exemplaire de cette entreprise mais au
delà de la création de ce ce site cette
ligne de production qui va permettre
d'être à la pointe de la recherche dans
le secteur
plusieurs dizaines d'embauchés la
consolidation du groupe
c'est aussi dans un processus de
relocalisation que c'est cointe s'est
engagé 12 molécules seront reproduits en
france dans les prochains mois et
prochaines années par votre engagement
le travail qui a été fait avec le
ministère de l'économie des finances et
de la santé 12 molécules dont certaines
d'ailleurs ont parfois manqué ont pu
manquer en est qu un an quasi pénurie je
pense au propofol dont on avait beaucoup
parlé en mars avril au moment justement
du pic de l'épidémie est donc c'est très
important dans la stratégie qui est la
nôtre aujourd'hui qu'avec nos
partenaires industriels ont réussi sa re
localiser alors c'est un mot qu'on a
souvent utilisé pour les uns c'était un
rêve impossible pour les autres un nom
non suivies d'actions
vous démontrez collection est là parce
qu'il ya un travail collectif
et c'est un travail qui n'a pas commencé
aujourd'hui au même hier 1er pilier qui
rend ces relocalisations possible c'est
le travail qui est fait depuis trois ans
nous avons profondément réformer la
fiscalité du capital et donc de
l'investissement en france profondément
réformer le marché du travail qui permet
l embauche profondément réformée aussi
le secteur de l'apprentissage qui a
littéralement explosé avant qu vide et
que nous sommes en train de consolider
sa fait partie des annonces qui ont été
faites aussi il ya quelques jours par le
premier ministre et les ministres
compétents compétents et nous avons
aussi profondément accélérée tout un
travail autour de notre industrie
je rappelle que début de l'année pour la
première fois depuis plus de 12 ans on a
recréé des emplois industriels en france
et donc ce socle là des trois dernières
années et ce qui rend possible justement
cette vague de relocalisation
le deuxième élément c'est ce qui a été
fait durant la crise depuis le premier
jour de la crise c'est-à-dire le travail
de résistance d'accompagnement des
secteurs les plus en difficulté que le
ministre de l'économie des finances avec
le premier ministre qui notait avec
l'ensemble des ministres sectoriels ce
sont 460 milliards d'euros qui ont été
investis depuis le premier jour de la
crise entre est garantie par l'état en
fonds de solidarité en chômage partiel
et en plomb sectorielle de
l'aéronautique à l'automobile en passant
par le tourisme
tout ça ce plan de résistance c'est ce
qui permet ensuite de dire on va
relocaliser quand on peut parce que
quand on laisse le tissu industriel où
les emplois les compétences se perdre au
pic de la crise il est très dur de
prétendre plus tard relocaliser et le
troisième volet c'est celui dans lequel
on rentre qui sera présenté la semaine
prochaine par le ministre à l'issue du
conseil des ministres du 3 septembre
c'est donc ce fameux plan de relance il
est dans la continuité ce travail je
veux le réinscrire ainsi et en
partenariat avec l'ensemble des secteurs
et des industriels parce qu'il a été
consul fait avec les industriels pour
que ces instruments répondent aux
besoins et donc ce plan de relance ce
cette stratégie france relance que nous
allons lancer ça n'est pas une stratégie
pour faire face aux difficultés du
moment ça nous l'avons déjà fait et nous
allons continuer pour tous les secteurs
qui le justifient jusqu'à la fin de
l'année non c'est préparer la france de
ça n'est pas subventionné les secteurs
en difficulté nous l'avons fait par tous
était nécessaire et utile c'est investir
dans l'avenir dans l'accélération de nos
transformation et de nos grandes
transitions c'est investir pour
transformer ces bâtir la france de
demain et donc projet france relance qui
sera présenté la semaine prochaine un
projet dans lequel nous voulons projeter
le pays pour plus d'indépendance et donc
leur localisation pour bâtir un modèle
d'avenir fondée sur le savoir sur
l'écologie et la transition écologique
qu'il s'agisse la rénovation des
thermiques des bâtiments ou de filières
comme l'hydrogène est de bâtir sur les
compétences c'est-à-dire d'investir dans
les femmes et les hommes et en
particulier notre jeunesse
c'est donc un plan d'investissement dans
notre avenir c'est un plan
d'investissement dans les françaises et
les français et en particulier les plus
jeunes pour les aider à obtenir un
emploi dans cette période si difficile a
continué à avoir les compétences et les
formations nécessaires
c'est ça la philosophie de ce plan de
relance de cette stratégie france que
france relance qui a été préparé depuis
des mois et dans ce contexte les
relocalisations joue pour nous un rôle
fondamental d'abord parce que c'est
montrer qu'il n'ya pas de fatalité et
c'est bâtir sur des secteurs d'avenir
comme en particulier le secteur
pharmaceutique
la capacité donc à relocaliser de la
production les deux molécules que
j'évoquais c'est derrière de la r&d du
processus industriel et de la capacité à
consolider le site de production france
mais aussi à notre capacité collective à
fournir des médicaments à nos
concitoyens nous allons le faire à
travers plusieurs actions d'abord
simplification de nos procédures les
autorisations temporaires d'utilisation
les fameuses à telus que connaissent
bien les professionnels du secteur
seront réformés de manière historique et
ce sera en place pour le 1er janvier
prochain
de telle sorte qu'on va réduire
drastiquement les délais on va pouvoir
innover plus simplement et plus vite en
france
c'est un des défauts que nous avions
historiquement on mène ce travail depuis
plusieurs mois même plusieurs années
avec les professionnels du secteur
permettre d'innover plus vite de mettre
sur le marché même de manière temporaire
plus rapidement un médicament qui est
très porteur d'innovation c'est
essentiel pour prétendre à localiser et
pour prétendre développer de nouvelles
molécules de nouveaux médicaments
la réforme des athées ou au 1er janvier
est un pilier de ce set france relance
on va plus vite on simplifie et investir
c'est pas seulement de l'argent c'est
faire gagner du temps aux entrepreneurs
aux industriels et à leurs salariés
la deuxième chose c'est qu'on va réduire
l'effort qui est demandé
chaque année aux entreprises du
médicament de 300 millions d'euros pour
le prochain plan de finances
parce que justement nous avons besoin de
laisser plus de marge de manoeuvre à ce
secteur qui est si stratégique dont on a
bien vu l'importance au moment de la
crise sanitaire et qui est à la fois
pour soigner nos concitoyens aujourd'hui
mais bâtir notre compétitivité de demain
un secteur stratégique pour notre pays
et puis nous allons investir massivement
sur les relocalisations dans le plan de
relance qui sera d'un peu plus de 100
milliards d'euros
il y aura 15 milliards pour l'innovation
et les relocalisations et en particulier
un milliard d'euros vraiment dette
acte construite avec les industriels
pour permettre sur des projets très
précis d'apporter une aide de l'état qui
aident à relocaliser c'est-à-dire a
parfois compenser pendant un temps donné
le petit déficit qu'on avait
historiquement et tout ça vient
évidemment se marier avec ce qui a été
annoncé par le premier ministre ministre
de l'économie des finances il ya
quelques jours c'est la baisse des
impôts de production historique aussi
sur les prochaines années
qui va permettre d'améliorer la
compétitivité du site productif france
en particulier sur le secteur industriel
et surtout ce qui est productif et le
plus qualifié
donc vous voyez c'est cette stratégie
d'ensemble qui est importante et nous
sommes aujourd'hui aux côtés d'un
industriel qui innovent dans un secteur
clé et qui va grâce à france relance
mais par aussi la volonté l'engagement
de ses salariés
relocaliser massivement dans les
prochains mois les prochaines années
voilà la philosophie de ce plan que je
voulais partager avec vous aujourd'hui
avant qu' il soit détaillé la semaine
prochaine et que dans les prochaines
semaines avec l'ensemble de nos
partenaires nous puissions ensuite le
décliner pour que le plus vite possible
ils permettent de bâtir cette france
ils permettent justement d'être dans ce
projet de conquête et pas simplement de
gestion du quotidien
bonjour aussi au président laurence
benhamou à sps que les nouvelles
contraintes sanitaires comme le masque
partout dans la rue dans les entreprises
ne risque pas d'entraver la relance
économique merci non je pense que ce qui
est important c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
nous faut d'abord protéger nos
concitoyens protéger en nous et qui pend
et en prévenant l'organisation notre
système de santé
le système de test l'organisation pour
isoler continuer le travail pour essayer
de trouver un traitement avec ça ensuite
il faut protéger au quotidien en
essayant de casser la circulation du
virus
ce sont les gestes barrière la stratégie
masque que vous venez de définir mais
aussi je le répète et je répète
constamment tenir les distances se laver
régulièrement les mains parce que le
match ne suffit pas à lui seul il faut
pas le prendre séparément mais on fait
ça justement parce que nous devons
continuer à vivre avec le virus est la
pire des choses ce serait d'être dans le
relâchement aujourd'hui pour laisser le
virus circule et plus rapidement ce qui
nous conduirait immanquablement à deir
confinement et donc des arts ea
d'activité notre pays a besoin pour
justement financer son modèle social
pour mieux protéger de continuer à
produire d'avoir une vie économique
notre pays a besoin pour éduquer les
enfants pour aussi soigner les plus
vulnérables qui ont d'autres pathologies
pour être fort produire avant c'est de
continuer à bâtir son avenir et donc
d'apprendre à vivre avec le virus
comme vous je n'aime pas porter un
masque
et on doit un peu apprendre à vivre avec
ça c'est gênant c'est pénible les gestes
barrière nous qui sommes plutôt un
peuple latin ne sont pas naturels dans
nos habitudes mais je pense que c'est
une contrainte qui est raisonnable que
nous devons accepter pendant un temps
parce qu'elle permet de ralentir la
circulation de ce virus
et justement elle permet à l'activité
économique de repartir dans de bonnes
conditions
après il ya des secteurs qui sont
évidemment très contraint certains
secteurs comme le secteur culturel on
sait de l'événementiel ou autres qu'on
va continuer à accompagner dans cette
période il faut avoir quelques
restrictions
bonjour monsieur président cédric pietra
lunga du monde plusieurs pays voisins
nous ont placés en liste rouge soit
toute la france soit certaines régions
du pays
le comprenez vous est ce à dire que
on n'a pas fait les choses suffisamment
vite suffisamment fort non je crois que
nous avons d'ailleurs nos concitoyens ne
lis pas je crois comme tel les choses
nous avons toujours prévenu alerté il ya
une responsabilité collective et
individuelle qu'il faut avoir
ensuite le virus circule et circule dans
beaucoup de régions d'europe dans tous
les pays d'europe une circule de manière
hétérogène selon les régions et en
fonction des concentrations mais la
plupart des capitales européennes sont
touchés aujourd'hui par une remontée du
virus et plusieurs régions à forte
densité ou attractivité touristique
leçon de l'espagne à l'allemagne en
passant par la belgique
ce à quoi j'appelle c'est plutôt la
coordination européenne et je pense que
ce qui est important c'est d'ailleurs ce
que la france a proposé au niveau
européen est-ce qu'il faut réussir à
faire aboutir dans les prochains jours
c'est de ne pas répéter les erreurs du
mois de mars dernier et la coordination
suppose de dire ayons les mêmes critères
ayons une bonne organisation qui permet
à l'europe de ne pas être à l'arrêt ça
n'a aucun sens de fermer les frontières
entre deux pays
quand il y à des foyers d'infection des
zones de circulation active comme on dit
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont bien identifiés
il faut plutôt avoir une méthodologie
commune pour définir ces zones de
circulation active et pour les traiter
au sein de chaque pays
c'est comme ça qu'il nous faut faire
parce que je le rappelle nous avons
partout en europe des millions de
travailleurs transfrontaliers qui
parfois vont d'une région à l'autre
entre deux pays qui elles ne sont pas
touchés et dont il serait absurde de
faire porter des contraintes parce que
ça vient entraver la vie quotidienne la
vie économique
donc je crois qu'on a encore des progrès
à faire pour améliorer la coordination
la france s'est engagée j'en ai parlé
avec la chancelière quand elle est venue
il ya quelques jours en france et nous
allons le vrai les prochains jours pour
justement avancées sur ce point je pense
qu'il faut améliorer mais voilà
ne répétons pas les erreurs du mois de
mars sur ce sujet c'est contre-productif
et c'est surtout inefficace dans la
lutte contre le virus et sa propagation
dans les points donc on va y aller je
remercie encore vraiment directeur
général l'entreprise s'est contenté et
l'ensemble de ses salariés
parce que vous avez montré à quel point
l'entreprise était faite de femmes et
d'hommes engagés au delà des
technologies est aussi inscrite dans un
territoire avec des actionnaires qui
vous font confiance et qui vous
accompagne et que je félicite et avec un
territoire aussi qui est derrière vous
dont vous savez embaucher les jeunes et
donc merci encore monsieur le maire de
nous avoir accueillis
merci à vous merci beaucoup